for many of us right now
our lives are quieter than normal and
quiet can be
unnerving it can make you feel lonely
we're just all too aware of the things
you're missing out on
i think about sound all the time i'm a
sound designer and i host the podcast 20
000 hertz
it's all about the world's most
recognizable and interesting sounds
but i think this is the perfect time to
talk about silence
because what i've come to understand is
that there is no such thing
as silence and the person who opened my
mind to this idea
is one of the most influential composers
in history
john cage has made an impact on artists
in many genres
from avant-garde musicians to modern
dance to pop music
right now we're listening to his 1948
piece called in a landscape
this version was recorded in 1994 by
steven drury
this piece is actually not very typical
of john cage's writing
he's more known for his innovations and
avant-garde techniques
but despite his reputation no one was
prepared for what he did
in 1952 when he created the most
daring piece of his career it was called
four minutes and 33 seconds and it was a
piece that
some critics even refused to call music
because for the entire duration of the
piece the performer plays
nothing at all well to be technical the
performer is actually playing
rest but to the audience it looks like
nothing's happening
john cage's 433 was performed for the
first time in the summer of 1952
by renowned pianist david tudor it was
at the maverick concert hall in
woodstock new york
this is a beautiful wooden building with
huge openings to the outdoors
so david tudor walked out on stage sat
down at the piano
then closed the piano lid he then sat in
silence
only moving to open and close the piano
lid between each of the three movements
after the time was up he got up and
walked off the stage
the audience had no idea what to think
it made people wonder if cage is even
taking his career seriously
a close friend even wrote to him begging
that he not turn his career into a joke
john cage had well if you could call it
composed a piece of music that
really challenged some very established
ideas about music composition
it's something that musicians still
debate today
to understand just what john cage was
thinking let's back up to the 1940s
back then john cage was making a name
for himself composing for the prepared
piano
to make music like this john cage would
put objects inside the piano
between the strings things you just find
lying around
like screws tape and rubber erasers
so now you've transformed the piano from
a tonal instrument with high and low
pitches
into a collection of unique sounds the
music you're hearing is cage's sonata
number five
from sonatas and interludes for prepared
piano probably his most famous work
outside of 433
this version was performed by boris
berman
john cage wrote incredibly detailed
instructions about where to place each
object in the piano
but it's impossible for every performer
to get the exact same
objects so the sound you get is always
different
basically it comes down to random chance
this was pretty bananas and pretty alien
to the way most composers and musicians
are taught to do things
john cage was becoming increasingly
interested in chance and randomness
and letting the universe provide the
answer to the question what note should
i play next
but to hear the answer to the question
first you have to listen
and in the 1940s listening to the
universe was getting harder to do
the music company was founded in the 30s
it really took off
and soon there was constant background
music nearly everywhere
it was almost impossible to escape john
cage realized that people were losing
the option to shut out the background
music of the world
he worried that musac would prevent
people from hearing silence altogether
in 1948 four years before he wrote 433
john cage mentioned that he wanted to
write a four and a half minute long
piece of silence
and sell it to the music company it
started as something of a political
statement
or an offhand comment but this idea
struck a nerve
and quickly evolved john cage was
starting to think
deeply about silence and when he visited
a truly quiet place
he made a startling discovery john cage
visited
an anechoic chamber at harvard
university anechoic chambers are rooms
that are acoustically treated to
minimize sound to almost
zero there are no sounds in these rooms
so
john cage didn't expect to hear anything
at all but he actually heard his own
blood
circulating i've personally experienced
an anechoic chamber and it's a really
wild experience that can completely
change your perceptions about
sound and silence it really felt like my
brain just turning up an
amplifier grasping for anything to hear
just like john cage i could very clearly
hear my blood pushing through my body
john cage realized in that moment
that no matter where we are even our
bodies are making
sound there's basically no such thing
as true silence as long as you are in
your body
you're always hearing something this is
where john cage's interest in chance and
randomness
met his interest in silence he realized
that creating an environment with no
distractions wasn't about creating
silence
it wasn't even about controlling noise
it was about the
sounds that were already there but you
suddenly hear for the first time
when you're really ready to listen
that's what's so often misunderstood
about 433
people assume it's a joke but that
couldn't be further from the truth
it sounds different everywhere you play
it and that's the point
what john cage really wanted us to hear
is the beauty of the sonic world around
us
[Music]
433 should be a mindful experience that
helps you focus on accepting things
just the way they are it's not something
that anyone else can tell you how you're
supposed to feel
it's deeply personal it also brings up
some
pretty big questions about our sonic
world
is 433 music is it sound is sound
music is there even a difference john
cage reminds
us that music isn't the only kind of
sound worth listening to
all sounds are worth thinking about we
have a once in a lifetime
opportunity to reset our ears and if we
become more conscious of what we hear
we'll inherently make our world sound
better
quietness is not when we turn off our
minds to sound
but when we can really start to listen
and hear the world in
all of its sonic beauty so in this
spirit
let's perform 433 together wherever you
are
it's three movements and i'll let you
know when they start listen to the
texture
and rhythm of the sounds around you
right now
listen for the loud and soft the
harmonic the dissonant
and all the small details that make
every sound
unique spend this time as mindful and
focused in this real
life sonic moment enjoy the magnificence
of
hearing and listening so here comes the
first movement
starting now
and here's movement two it'll be two
minutes and 23 seconds
and here's the final movement it'll be
one minute and 40 seconds
and that's it we did it thanks for
listening
[Music]